each of my siblings remembers that night
in the bedroom
with me standing there in the doorway i
watched my father punch my mother so
hard that she spit up blood
that moment probably more than any other
moment in my life has defined who i am
today will smith gets deeply candid
about his childhood and his mother's
abusive relationship with his father in
his new youtube original series best
shape of my life there was so many
kind of highs and lows on the emotional
front you know i cried you know during
the filming you know which i'm not a big
crier it was shock you know it was like
profound moments of insight and
revelations on thursday episode five of
will's six-episode docu-series dropped
the episodes follow the 53-year-old
actor as he reflects on his upbringing
for his new memoir will
daddy o was one of the greatest
blessings of my life
and also one of my greatest sources of
pain
there were two issues
first he had a brutal temper
and second his drinking when he was
angry or drunk he became an idiot he
would break his own rules subvert his
own objectives destroy his own things
my mom is in many ways the total
opposite of my father whereas daddy-o
was the boisterous charismatic center of
attention my mom carried a quiet
reserved elegance will recalls one
particularly bad night when his father
hit his mother so hard she spit up blood
each of my siblings responded
differently in ways that would go on to
define who we were for much of our lives
if harry was fight
ellen was flight and i became a pleaser
i wanted to please and placate him
because as long as daddio was laughing
and smiling i believed we would be safe
my little nine-year-old brain processed
daddio's abusive episodes as somehow
being my fault
i should have been able to keep my
father satisfied i should have been able
to protect my mother the pursuit of
happiness star added that he carried the
guilt of doing nothing to help her in
that moment for a lifetime my young
identity congealed in my mind an
unshakable feeling that no matter what i
have done no matter how successful i've
become no matter how much money i've
made or how many number one hits i've
had how many box office records i've
broken
there's that subtle and silent feeling
always pulsating in the back of my mind
that i'm a coward
that i failed
that i'm sorry my mom so sorry will's
mom carolyn eventually left his father
and moved a couple of miles away to live
with will's grandmother gigi and carolyn
joined will after reading the chapter
for the first time that was the only
time in my life
that i ever considered suicide we never
talked about it
um
the idea that i felt like i should have
done something was so
you know foreign
[Music]
you know so she uh
reassured
uh little will that there was nothing
that
he could have done will's self-titled
memoir is full of refreshingly candid
reflections in the deeply personal book
he also opens up about his sex life with
his wife jada pinkett smith whom he
married back in 1997. our marriage was
the most difficult grueling and
excruciating thing that we've ever
taken on in our lives and you know we're
just not quitters we only ever worked on
ourselves individually and then
presented ourselves to one another
better than we were previously during a
recent sit down with oprah winfrey for
her series the oprah conversation on
apple tv plus she read an excerpt from
the book where will talks about the
early days of their relationship as far
as i was concerned there were only two
possibilities i was going to satisfy
this woman sexually or i was going to
die try
and while the couple may have been hot
and heavy back then will says it was and
still is deeper than that me and jada to
this day if we start talking
it's four hours it's four hours if we
exchange a sentence really yeah and it's
like it's
uh it's the center of
why we've been able to sustain and you
know
why we're still
together not
choking the life out of each other
all that echoes what will told et about
how they make it work back in 2007 it is
not your responsibility to make your
wife happy right
just like it's not my wife's
responsibility to make me happy
it's my responsibility to make me happy
and it's her responsibility to make her
happy and then we're going to come
together
and build on that happiness as for jada
will says she was never interested in a
traditional marriage in fact she didn't
even want a wedding their union it's all
about bettering themselves and coming
together stronger will and jada
are
on a spiritual journey to cleanse the
poisonous unloving parts of our hearts
wow
and
we're doing it together
in this lifetime
no matter what